une sixième vague était inévitable après
les fêtes comment sortir de cette
pandémie les vaccins sont ils aussi
efficace face aux variants omicron on
attend vos avis sur le conte télégramme
adhère t france tout de suite ces débats
et sur ce plateau l'infectiologue pierre
tattevin bonsoir vous êtes le chef des
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes
présent également pour évoquer cette
cinquième voire sixième vague
arnaud chiche
réanimateur anesthésiste en direct d'un
moment vous êtes le fondateur du
collectif santé en danger et puis là
gilles bonnefond porte parole de l'union
à syndicale des pharmaciens bonsoir
messieurs merci de répondre à nos
questions arnaud chiche je commence avec
vous êtes le fondateur du collectif
santé en danger est ce qu'on est en
danger face à ce variant omicron
bon jeu je déteste faire
l'annonciateur de deux mauvaises
nouvelles donc il faut pas je pense
qu'il ne sert à rien de 2,2 d'être dans
le misérabilisme et d'être dans la dans
la fatalité et deux de trop souffler sur
deux sur des dans des directions qui
ferait peur aux français il faut essayer
d'avoir un discours quand même positif
alors le discours positif c'est que la
vaccination
va fonctionner contre ce variant
peut-être un peu moins bien mais d'un
autre côté j'ai écouté le professeur
flahault tout à l'heure qui disait que
la troisième dose risque d'entraîner
vraiment une immunité très intéressante
contre ce variant et de là tout là tout
l'intérêt et mais je me garderai bien
d'aller trop loin parce que vous avez un
un éminent spécialiste sur votre plateau
mais tout l'intérêt des vaccins à arn
c'est justement d'être capable après de
s'adapter et s'il faut faire un nouveau
vaccin y aura un nouveau vaccin s'il ya
besoin c'est tout toute façon les
français ont compris ce virus qui mute
et que les que la manière de réagir et
bien ce sera évidemment peut être
d'améliorer le vaccin mais une fois que
j'ai dit ça
mon inquiétude à moi est toujours la
même depuis 18 mois c'est à dire depuis
le sigle ior de la santé
l'exécutif ne prend pas
la mesure exacte du système de santé
français voilà donc j'ai l'impression de
répéter ça comme un perroquet depuis des
mois et des mois et des mois et des mois
aujourd'hui par exemple à draguignan
dans des villes comme draguignan comme
laval il ya des services d'urgence qui
sont fermées ou alors qu'ils ferment la
nuit est inondée vie à l'hôpital débit
navale il manque du personnel
la vaccination est évidemment la mesure
principale à encourager et ma foi quand
même en france le taux de vaccination il
est pas mal hélas insuffisant et dans le
monde dont maxime on essaye signe le
plus souvent possible mais tout l'ethnie
du monde sont confrontés aussi à une
insuffisance de leur système de sempé à
un moment donné les gens il faut les
soigner avec des infirmières avec des
lits et de médecins avec de l'oxygène
avec des médicaments et mon angoisse si
qu'aujourd'hui même avant le pic de la
vague même avant la sixième vague on a
déjà du mal à soigner tout le monde on
est déjà en plan blanc dans beaucoup
d'hôpitaux en france on est déjà dans
certains hôpitaux en train de
déprogrammer et donc si vous voulez je
trouve complètement schizophrénique mon
analyse donc le c'est normal voilà mais
de la part de l'exécutif
je trouve qu'ils offraient nick
d'informer les français sur les vagues
et à venir sur les pics possible et sur
les mesures à prendre pour noël sans
annoncer aux français qu' on à pilsen
que qu'ils avaient pris conscience des
insuffisances et de l'état d'épuisement
l'état de décider soignante de france
parce que malgré tout autour des
problèmes dans tous les sens à un moment
donné faut quand même être capables de
soigner les gens car même s'ils sont
complètement vaccinés en sait bien on
sait bien que des progrès des problèmes
à l'hôpital on se souvient également un
livre sur cinq fermes à l'hôpital
olivier ferrand on avait parlé récemment
un pierre tattevin je me tourne vers
vous
cette sixième vague on commence à en
parler alors qu on est simplement dans
la cinquième vague est ce qu'on met pas
un peu la charrue avant les boeufs du
côté de l'ap-hp c'est vrai que la
sémantique est un peu étonnante parce
qu'on sait pas si ça va être une sixième
vague ou si ça va juste être la
continuité de ce qu'on vit actuellement
mais ce qui est certain c'est que le
haut mikron va prendre la place du delta
il l'a fait dans les autres pays et il
va le faire en france aussi et on a
entendu à arnaud chiche qui parle d'un
problème au niveau du système
hospitalier au delà de la pandémie est
ce que vous au chu de rennes vous vivez
ça également absolument un c'est un
constat généralisée c'est à dire que
cette vague c de cinquième vague arrive
sur des systèmes de santé qui sont en
tension qui avait déjà du mal à fendre
distension pourtant j'ai envie de
rappeler quand même une étude je me
permets de vous couper on se souvient
d'un rapport qui a fait grand bruit fin
octobre de la tiéhi h l' agence
technique sur l'information sur
l'hospitalisation
selon l'étude ya eu seulement 2% de
passion qu'ovide en 2020 et 5% en
réanimation donc une sixième vague
vraiment j'ai envie de dire car avant
même cette vague de kovy dans avait déjà
des problèmes parce qu'il ya des
services d'urgence confirmer parce que
les à des manques de personnels dans
certaines unités notamment réanimation
donc c'est vrai qu'il faut revoir le
dimensionnement de notre système de
santé c'est vraiment une un constat
partagé par tous sur le terrain alors on
va le dimensionnement de notre système
de santé en passant par les pharmaciens
je me tourne vers vous gilles bonnefond
les pharmaciens sont appelés à vacciner
les dimanches vous avez dit récemment
que vous alliez demandé du renfort au
ministre de la santé que vous ne pouviez
pas vacciner sans prise de rendez vous à
ce que vous avez été entendue écoutée
par olivier ferrand où nous sommes le
dossier est à l'étude en fin de compte
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que on
vaccine en ville les pharmaciens 60% des
injections qu'ovide donc déjà c'est un
travail énorme on a fait quatre millions
d'injections contre la grippe 17
personnes de plus que l'année dernière
et surtout on existe trois millions de
personnes par semaine
autant dire autant dire que là la
pression est forte en plus du travail
normal de fond du renouvellement des
ordonnances et des épidémies liées à
l'hiver
nous bien évidemment on a bien
conscience du danger qui est devant nous
on se mobilise et ce que l'on dit c'est
que l'effort doit être partagé
avec les infirmiers avec les étudiants
en médecine avec les médecins parce que
s'il ya des volontaires le dimanche et
puis mission de venir en renfort des
centres vaccination on veut bien être
volontaire et il faut que l'effort soit
partagé et donc pour qu'il soit partagé
on demande la possibilité de considérer
le centre d'un pharmacien comme un
centre de vaccination ce qui permet de
régler un certain nombre de problèmes de
recrutement et de recrutement dans des
durées très courtes pas me recruter
quelqu'un pour une planche matin faire
un contrat de travail payer des charges
sociales et tout ça est trop compliqué
donc bondi facilité nous lâche la tâche
et les pharmaciens qui seront
volontaires auront ce travail parce que
la vaccination tout le monde a bien
compris que ce vaccin était efficace
contre le delta c'est le delta qui
circulent aujourd'hui le messie de même
y passer par le micro mais pour la fin
de l'année c'est le delta qui peut faire
des dégâts dont il faut se vacciner
c'est efficace contre le micro et après
on verra la stratégie vaccinale un petit
peu plus tard mais pour l'instant
l'objectif c'est de vacciner tout le
monde avec cette troisième dose pour les
plus de 65 ans et je crois que le
message aussi qui est important c'est de
se dépister avant les faits
ne venez pas en pharmacie si vous n'avez
pas de symptômes on est déjà débordée
prenez des autotests juste avant la
réunion familiale vous tester c'est
facile à utiliser si c'est positif c'est
dommage la réunion vous devez être exclu
de la réunion pas infecté tout le monde
et si vous êtes le négatif
et vous continuez également prendre des
précautions vous embrasser pas ou laver
les mains et puis faites attention pour
pas justement
contribuer à la circulation du virus
dans cette période ô oui les autres
quand on vous écoute on a l'impression
de revenir à il ya un an pratiquement
jour pour jour où on entendait toutes
ces précautions ces mesures le fait de
de se faire vacciner également les
nombreux à être vaccinés pourtant le
virus est toujours présent et la
cinquième vague est forte on parle même
de sixième vague escape à un paradoxe on
est vaccinés mais il ya quand même
énormément énormément de cas pire tu es
devant la situation c'est qu'on a cet
hiver un variantes les plus contagieux
le delta et un derrière qui le sera
encore plus et puis qu'on arrive à peu
au bout de l'efficacité de la
primovaccination qu'on a tous fait au
premier semestre 2021 enfin beaucoup de
journaux fait à ce moment là et donc on
arrive à la fin du deuxième sommet
justement se faire vacciner là tous les
cinq mois force est ce que c'est
vraiment avec sa housse est plus un
traitement non non on a bon espoir
d'après ce qu'ils ont mesuré avec les
anticorps chez les gens qui reçoivent la
troisième dose ne pas avoir besoin de le
faire tous les six mois il en faut une
troisième pour ses douze de rappel c'est
vraiment parce que le professeur
delfraissy il n'a pas vraiment dit ça
dernièrement d'ailleurs on peut
peut-être juste voir ce qu'a dit le
professeur delfraissy et après je me
suis garé son intervention devait avouer
j'entends parfois que la vaccination
contre le coc vide ce sont deux
injections et un rappel moi je vous dis
aujourd'hui que je ne sais pas pour
l'instant c'est un rappel mais peut-être
qu'il en faudra un deuxième je ne sais
pas c'est un point important dans une
crise de ce type je pense qu'il faut
qu'on dise tout ce qu'on sait qu'on le
mette sur la table pour qu'on partage ce
qu'on sait et ce qu'on ne sait pas donc
on parle de la troisième dose en ce
moment le professeur delfraissy évoque
une quatrième dose et en l'espace de peu
de temps il dit quand même trois fois je
ne sais pas oui mais il a raison de le
dire en fait ça ne veut pas dire il ne
dit pas qu'il va falloir le faire tous
les six mois la plupart des vaccins ce
qu'on fait aux enfants ont fait deux
injections ont fait un rappel six mois
après il faut faire quelques années plus
tard et c'est quelque chose qu'on
découvrira avec le recul quand on aura
suivi des anti corps des patients on
saura s'il faut réinjecter un nom à 2
ans à 5 ans mais c'est pas parce qu'il
faut le faire à 6 mois maintenant qu'on
aura besoin de le faire tous les six
mois ça c'est un message important tous
les cas là vous comprenez quand même les
français qui se pose beaucoup de
questions qui sont un peu
déconcerté décontenancé quand on voit
tout ça oui surtout cerexhe qui nous a
pas aidé c'est que le vaccin est sorti
en urgence et que donc les schémas
nécessaires n'étaient pas connues on
savait qu'il fallait en faire deux pour
avoir beaucoup d'anti corps mais on ne
savait pas quand on a démarré qu'il
faudrait leur faire à six mois il aurait
été beaucoup mieux acceptée probablement
si on avait dit aux gens on commence
avec deux aides en six mois on vous
rappellera et on ne pouvait pas le dire
parce qu'on ne savait pas et jean
françois delfraissy il dit bien donc il
faut que les français comprennent qu'il
ya des choses qu'on découvre en cours de
route et en même temps arnaud chiche l'a
dit et c'est vraiment important on a
avec cette troisième dose une très bonne
efficacité qui protège nos hôpitaux qui
nous procure une étude britannique on
parle de 75 % d'efficacité face aux
variants au omicron justement je me
tourne vers vous et arnaud chiche
est-ce qu'on a suffisamment de recul ces
variants omikron le connais depuis quoi
une quinzaine de jours il a apparu en
afrique du sud on parle déjà d'une
efficacité à 75% de ce qu'on a
suffisamment de recul pour dire c'est
bon
75 % on peut se recevoir cette troisième
dose on va être protégés face aux
variants mikron
on manque un peu de temps on manque un
peu de temps aux scellés il faut bien
comprendre que pendant il te manque de
temps encore par ses réponses là c'est
pas pour gagner du temps par contre
qu'on vous dit ça c'est la vérité vous
avez bien comment ça se passe locaux
vides on a les infos un peu au fur et à
mesure on est en train de vivre une
épidémie en live cirque on n'a pas
tellement de référence antérieure et
donc on doit avoir l'humilité et ça je
comprends bien pour les français c'est
difficile à comprendre à entendre mais
nous vous allez il faut bien comprendre
que nous les médecins les scientifiques
depuis le premier jour où on a dû
soigner si le patient là on n'a pas
cessé d'apprendre des nouveaux signes
cliniques des nouvelles prise en charge
thérapeutique
on est dans un moment de grande
plasticité où les informations elle
arrive elle arrive at au fur et à mesure
mais je voudrais encore une fois appuyé
mon propos je pense que c'est de la
responsabilité de nous justement
scientifique de dire aux types elle et
de dire à l'exécutif et je le professeur
pas devin mais j'ai besoin de gens comme
vous monsieur pour appuyer le propos
parce qu'en fait je trouve
vraiment étant dit je vais être vulgaire
dégueulasse de faire peur aux français
en leur parlant du prochain mario en
leur parlant des risques en leur parlant
des interrogations mais les tutelles
aujourd'hui elles ont une obligation
c'est de dire qu'avant de faire un grand
plan santé pour dire aux français on
sait qu'ils votre santé sera garanti
avec des soignants qui s'y arrêteront
d'ailleurs dès les 19 meilleurs c'est
pas un grand plan eh bien écoutez
monsieur écoutez monsieur j'aurais aimé
j'aurais tenté et j'aurais tenté mais il
faut comprendre que le deux tuiles ségur
de la santé ça s'est même aggravée
est-ce qu'on peut tout ce qui a été fait
at elle mal je ne sais pas comment ils
ont dépensé ces milliards là mais
aujourd'hui les résultats sont là il n'y
a jamais eu autant de 10 fermé en france
il n'y a jamais eu autant de services
d'urgence permis ya jamais eu autant de
médecins qui dit que les eaux plutôt
demandé le jeu taden dans les chu dans
les chu qui manquent des médecins
partout partout partout
donc soit l'état
alone et devient le ségur est
insuffisant on en a pris conscience on
va faire mieux et vous savez on parle
beaucoup de l'hôpital et péter chu mais
je vois mon collègue pharmaciens on peut
transposer exactement la même réflexion
pour la ville pour tous les métiers de
la ville interrogé les médecins
généralistes aujourd'hui parfois ils ont
30% 40% de leur temps administratif on
les embête avec des fichiers
administratifs à remplir c'est autant de
temps qu'ils n'ont pas pour aller voir
alors du premier conflit loin d'avoir
fait de parler de la surcouche
administrative qui a beaucoup qui a
beaucoup été un frein à tout ce qui
s'est passé lors du premier confidence
je me tourne vers vous et gilles
bonnefond vous avez dit tout à l'heure
avant les fêtes de fin d'année allez
vous tester
respectez les gestes barrière justement
le conseil scientifique a publié
aujourd'hui son avis sur la situation
épidémique en cette fin d'année et
recommande donc de limiter le nombre de
personnes à table au repas de noël de
s'assurer que les convives et bien reçu
leur dose de rappel ça rappelle pas un
peu quand même ce qui s'est passé l'an
passé papy et mamie mange la puce dans
la cuisine le côté infantilisation est
ce que est ce que ça va pas revenir sur
le devant de la scène je ne pense pas
que ce soit de l'infantilisation c'est
de rappeler simplement les bons réflexes
de 10 sensation social d'hygiène de
faire attention de par brassées je pense
que c'est du bon sens on sait que les
virus se transmet comme ça donc on
réexplique on rappelle vraiment les
français ça veut dire qu'il est les
français ont complètement oublié ça oui
oui ils ont ils ont relâché on s'est
relâché on a enlevé les masques plus tôt
on a on a moins fait attention on
commence à se faire embrasser au fait
des soirées on commence à faire des pots
etc faire la bamba a dit martial oui
mais si simplement dans les bus
circulent pas on peut retrouver une
activité quasi normale dans une rue
circule il faut retrouver les bons
réflexes le virus n'a jamais circulé
aussi vite et aussi fort avec comme vous
le disiez invariants delta beaucoup plus
contaminant donc on reprend les bons
réflexes et on évite de
propager le virus et donc le succès qu
on doit comprendre c'est que la
vaccination n'est pas une porte qui se
ferme et qui empêche le virus de rentrer
dans le corps sauf que quand ils
rentrent et bien on à l'outil pour le
l'attaqué beaucoup plus vite donc on est
moins contaminant parce que sa charge
virale et diminue puis on passe on a
moins de risques de se retrouver aux
urgences et un service de réanimation à
l'hôpital mais ça n'empêche pas de
l'attraper il vaut mieux ne pas
l'attraper et donc ne pas l'attraper et
éviter la circulation les gestes
barrière voilà il faut le rappeler
savait juste avant les vacances de
toussaint on a dit aux enfants vous
pouvez enlever le masque n'était pas de
circulation de virus manque de chance
juste à la rentrée il faut remettre le
masque est donc grand problème que c'est
un effort pour les gamins de se remettre
à le masquer tout ça c'est très
difficile à gérer parce qu'on n'était
pendant une chose qu'on ne maîtrise pas
c'est la circulation du virus et sa
virulence voilà donc on s'adapte et je
trouve franchement pas mal d'agilité or
on peut regretter ces petits êtres
chiche et enfin on fait le constat que
ça manque de moyens est très très
longtemps sauf que là on a dix jours
pour essayer de casser de fer que le
bateau ne redescende parce que l'on se
sort bien organisés en fait nous
vacciner geste par une distanciation
sociale et paca et les fêtes de noël ou
bien on est d'épissage même pas s'il est
positif et une augmentation de séjour à
l'hôpital au mois de janvier voilà c'est
ça l'enjeu visiblement des restrictions
sanitaires supplémentaires il l'a dit
olivier ferrand ce week-end dans les
colonnes du parisien y'a pas de re de
confinement de prévu mais rien est
impossible il faut lire entre les lignes
ci commence à parler de leur confinement
même s'il dit qu'il ya pas de
confinement de prévu c'est pour préparer
la population un confinement c'est ça
moi moi je vois plutôt ça comme de
l'honnêteté c'est de dire qu'on sait pas
ce qui va se passer il faut faire
attention éviter ça et je pense que
toutes les règles qui sont proposées par
le conseil scientifique là c'est pour
essayer d'éviter pire et on peut y
arriver on vaccine bientôt le monde on
fait attention pendant les fêtes et on
peut espérer que ce soit suffisamment
raisonnables au mois de janvier pour
qu'on puisse garder cette façon de vivre
qu'on a actuellement en attendant des
jours meilleurs est donc évitée sets 7/6
vague prédit martin hirsch le mot de la
fin pour vous rapidement arnaud chiche
cool cool jallet j'avais pris une petite
note en écoutant en écoutant vos invités
moi je suis bien c'est bien que de
réaffirmer les gestes barrière
l'aération d'encourager la vaccination
tout ça c'est des mots clés je suis à
peu près certain que les français n'ont
pas oublié ce que c'est et les gestes
barrières et qui vont faire gaffe à noël
par contre je suis absolument certain
que l'état français a oublié ses
soignants j'avance malhonnête vous avez
levé la main gilles bonnefond rapidement
ouais un petit bout d'optimisme moi je
trouve que les français se sont bien
comportés on a quand même plus de 52
millions de français qui sont vaccinées
il reste encore entre 5 et 6 millions
qui ne sont pas vaccinés qui aurait
parié un tel résultat au mois de mai
donc il y a j'ai une prise de conscience
de la part des français de bien se
protéger contre ce virus parce que ce
virus est dangereux et 120 milles mans
en france à cause de ce virus et bien
c'est quelque chose il doit interpeller
parce que c'est 120 g familiaux 120
décès dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles et on comment on pas que ce
virus commence à attaquer les jeunes
donc voilà je trouve que mes rares
d'autres pays et bien sûr vous fait les
français se sont assez bien mobiliser
contre ce virus merci messieurs d'avoir
répondu à nos questions
merci donc gilles bonnefond je rappelle
que vous êtes le porte parole de l'union
syndicale des pharmaciens merci arnaud
chiche médecin anesthésiste réanimateur
et fondateur du collectif santé en
danger et puis pierre tattevin
infectiologues chef du service des
maladies infectieuses au chu de rennes